genau ich stelle mich wahnsinnig auf
über den paragrafen 219 a
strafgesetzbuch und zwar stellt der
unter strafe wenn kliniken oder ärzte
werbung machen für den
schwangerschaftsabbruch
das bedeutet wenn man ärzte hat oder
kliniken die eine homepage haben und
dort vor kurzem war es so dass sobald
sie über schwangerschaftsabbrüche
informiert haben also einfach nur gesagt
haben ja wir machen das dass man sie
dann an zeigen konnte und sie sich dann
strafbar gemacht haben das wurde jetzt
vor kurzem chef
informiert
jetzt ist es so dass man jetzt zwar
auskunft geben können aber sie dürfen
nicht sagen wie genau der
schwangerschaftsabbruch vorgenommen wird
also medikamentös oder durch eine op und
ich finde das ist ein absolutes unding
wie so aus zwei gründen erstens werden
staunen hier als unmündige wesen gesehen
die
wahrscheinlich glauben abschreibungen
jugend mache ich es überhaupt kein
problem für mich das gegenteil ist der
fall also vor allem junge frauen die
sehr häufig betroffen sind von
abschreibungen
für die ist es ja keinen spaß also dass
es geht ja immer mit so schweren
traumatischen folgen einher und dass man
staunen so hinstellt als ob sie das
einfach nur aus spaß machen würden finde
ich sehr problematisch und auch ein
bisschen sexistisch der andere grund ist
es gibt immer weniger ärzte die den
schwangerschaftsabbruch durchführen ein
beispiel es gibt daten vom statistischen
bundesamt 2002 waren als 2000 stellen
also kliniken oder ärzte die das
durchgeführt haben ende 2020 waren es
nur noch 1000 also fast ein rückgang von
50 prozent und das führt dazu dass
selbst frauen die vergewaltigt worden
sind und ihre schwangerschaft abbrechen
wollen bis zu 100 kilometer manchmal 200
kilometer fahren müssen um eine klinik
oder ein arzt zu finden
das kann einfach nicht sein
andechs und wieso es immer weniger ärzte
gibt ist auch die kriminalisierung
von schwangerschaftsabbrüchen
per se weil
der paragraph 218 jahr das ganze
kriminalisiert und dadurch abschreibungs
ärzte schon unter generalverdacht stehen
und immer wieder in die schmuddelecke
geschenkt werden unter kollegen
bei kliniken aber auch durch
abtreibungsgegner die sie anfangs die
teilweise plastik führten nehmen sie in
den briefkasten werfen um die
moralischen druck auszuüben dass sie
diese abstellungen nicht mehr vornehmen
und deswegen forderte ich den cut
geschafft der pakt auf 219 a muss
komplett weg da haben wir auch gute
aussichten mit der ampel und meiner
meinung nach sollte man auch einem
schwangerschafts abbrüche komplett
entkriminalisieren und deswegen auch der
paragraph 218 weg landet also ich meine
teile diese auffassung
dass der paragraph 219 ersatzlos quasi
aus dem strafgesetzbuch raus muss ich
bin selbst früher in der
kommunalpolitik aktiv gewesen und gerade
dort hat man oft frauen erlebt die in so
einer situation waren und gerade in so
einer schwierigen situation braucht man
ja informationen und darum geht es und
sie haben ja auch angesprochen die die
situation der ärzte angesprochen und
diese ärzte haben ja immer zu uns gesagt
ja wir hätten aber gerne einfach
verlässliche regeln wie wir
informieren können und wie wir unsere
dienstleistung
informationsdienstleistungen dann auch
anbieten können und das ist in der tat
schwierig gewesen weil das sind das ist
eigentlich ein unding
sich zu informieren menschen die sich
informieren wollen quasi als kriminelle
dann darzustellen das ist aus meiner
sicht ein unding absolut nicht zeitgemäß
und ignoriert vollständig die situation
in der sich dann auch die idee menschen
dann konkret befinden ja also allein das
wort
werbung.de kliniken macht man keine
werbung also werbung bedeutet wirklich
das ist eher etwas werbung macht nein
sie wollen einfach nur informieren das
ist ja auch so sehr wichtig wie man
darauf spezialisiert ist und das ist
natürlich
haben die die ärzte dann auch keine lust
diesen besuch auszuüben und es gibt auch
in der ausbildung also wenn man sich die
medizinerausbildung anguckt wird es
einfach viel zu wenig angeboten und muss
wirklich eine klinik gehen wo diese
abstriche vorgenommen werden dann kann
man das lernen aber welcher junge arzt
hatten lust darauf mit einfluss und
klasse zu stehen die ärzte sagen immer
ganz klar wir können nicht objektiv
beraten weil uns einfach die regeln an
der stelle nicht klar sind und das ist
ein großes problem
es war lange zeit ist deine partei
dieses sozusagen verhindert hat meines
erachtens zu recht und ich finde das
krass gerade auch was jetzt zuletzt
somit rein geworfen wurde ich bin der
überzeugung missbraucht führen um eine
abtreibung zu gehen und es gibt eine
rechtliche grundlage in deutschland die
es möglich macht und bestimmten fällen
eine abtreibung durchzuführen aber ich
halte nichts davon dass auch nur in
irgendeiner weise zu lockern ich bin der
festen lass mich das kurze ende wenn ich
bin der festen überzeugung dass wir für
jedes leben in diesem land kämpfen
müssen und was war denn das beispiel der
vergewaltigung angeführt dass es für
mich ganz extremes wo ich sicherlich der
karibik also ich möchte mir nicht
vorstellen müssen dass ich von also das
überhaupt sowas durchführen bei mir
passiert aber am ende was bringt es mir
denn zu wissen dass mein frauenarzt das
durchführt weil ich muss vorher so oder
so zu irgendeiner
schwangerschaftsberatung die mir danach
sagt wo ich anfangen kann und das ist so
wichtig dass ich zu dieser
beratungsstelle gegen hannover kinder
dadurch noch mal retten kann ja aber
dadurch dadurch habe ich ja auch nichts
gesagt also dass du es gibt das
hauptproblem ist dass die ärzte immer
weniger werden dass auch gesund man ja
aber es hilft ja das ist ja dass das
auftreten von § 209 10 haben nein wir
haben erst heute morgen ganz generell
und die gynäkologen
das hat nichts damit zu tun das hat was
wirklich mit der mit der moralischen
stigmatisierung von abtreibungsärzten zu
tun die schon während der ausbildung
durch diese gesetzgebung die als
kriminalisiert keine lust haben das zu
machen weil sich dann als moralischer
mensch darstellt und ganz viel
widerstand bekommen nicht nur von den
aktivisten sondern auch von den kollegen
teilweise in den städten usw und solange
wir diesen paragraphen kriminalisiert
haben und wir können in den außer gucken
da ist eben nicht so gut mal abgesehen
von texas der wurde jetzt gesagt
verschärft aber die gesetzgebung in den
usa
legalisiert damit den akt an sich nicht
per se also wir haben auch eines der
schärfsten gesetze mit in europa das
muss man auch mit da zu sein und wenn
man einfach nur
die absage aus dieser schmuddelecke
herausholen und sie endlich realisiert
dann könnte man dieses problem sehr wohl
gehe vor allen dingen du hast
angesprochen so du bist ja keine hürden
der frei machen also es geht ja hier
wirklich um informationen und ich finde
man wenn man sich in diese diese jungen
damen und oder generell frauen
hineinversetzt die sind ja die sind ja
verzweifelt die sind ja oft beschämt die
trauen sich mit niemanden darüber zu
reden vor allem den meistens nicht mit
den eltern und da ist es doch das sollte
doch das normalste sein dass ich mich im
heutigen zeitalter über das internet
informieren kann was passiert da
überhaupt was wir finden solche
abteilungen stadt und an wen kann ich
mich wenden und welcher arzt meines
vertrauens weil vielleicht wollen sie
gar nicht zuerst zu irgendeiner
schwangerschaftsberatung vielleicht
wollen die am anfang lieber zu ihrem
persönlichen gynäkologen oder zu ihrem
hausarzt des vertrauens gehen und
darüber medien sprechen aber da haben
wir gleich drei unterschiedliche punkte
erstens wenn du dich informieren möchte
ist bekommt so die informationen im
internet zweitens wenn du zeit also das
ist ja überhaupt nicht gewährleistet
dass dein persönlicher gynäkologe das
überhaupt durchführt also ich würde gern
nachschauen können im internet darf wenn
ich einmal rein schreiben dass es macht
auch weil das was darf man mittlerweile
schon weil es wurde ja davon ob vor
kurzem zögern denn man darf die details
also man darf das bringt nämlich man
aber nicht mehr aber nicht mehr die
beschreibung ist genauso wie nach wie
vor wie vorgenommen dass diese person
dann völlig isoliert sind informieren
sich informieren wollen und nicht an
dieser information werden kommen also
was was gerade einer frau die in so
einer situation so einer solch
schwierigen situation ist was würdet ihr
dann empfehlen
es ist leider recht statisch geregelt
wie das abläuft also ich möchte eine
abtreibung durchführen ich weiß dass ich
drei tage vorher muss ich zu einem
schwangerschaftsberatung oder zu einem
konflikt beratung gehen die erklären
wofür mit mir noch ein gespräch da gibt
es ein paar lustige feiern mit da
hinterher
lustig ist das alles nicht also gab es
hinterher ein paar flyer und die sagen
okay diese diese ärzte umkreis führen
dass durch und geben quasi ihr go wenn
du das machen möchtest wenn du damit
hier am rhein bis dann tue es halt und
ich finde dass man auf dem weg zu einer
abtreibung genau solche beratungen und
solche informationen stellen in einer
anderen ebene eben braucht und ich
verstehe dieses jahr ich muss mich mit
meinen arzt noch darüber unterhalten die
information gibt es ja de facto und wer
sagt mir dass meine absicht überhaupt
mit mir darüber unterhält und ich dass
mein arzt mehr am ende dann sowieso da
total nachspiel ist auf gut deutsch
gesagt mir erzählt macht das auf gar
keinen fall und ich für das erst recht
nicht wo ist hier schwer ist ein anderer
zu reden also schwere natürlich
irgendwann immer zu einer
schwangerschaft hat das stimmt aber
tatsächlich meine liebe